but we begin this morning with the
about-face by President Trump on how to
address the influx of illegal immigrants
and asylum seekers Crockett crossing
into the u.s. from Mexico on Thursday
White House aides reportedly had
suggested illegal immigrants should be
sent to so-called sanctuary cities in
democratic strongholds but the White
House said he'd quickly dismissed the
proposal on Friday however President
Trump embraced the idea Steve Dorsey is
at the White House this morning Steve
good morning good morning the White
House had told reporters the plan was
considered informally and rejected by
the Department of Homeland Security last
year now it appears the president is
ready to square off with sanctuary
cities and punish opponents in liberal
strongholds so we're always saying they
have open arms let's see if they have
open arms President Trump says if cities
are harboring illegal immigrants then
they should get more of them well bring
the illegal early I call them the
illegals I call me illegals they came
across the border illegally we'll bring
them to sanctuary city areas and let
that particular area take care of it the
president had already threatened to
withhold federal funding to so-called
sanctuary cities that refused to enforce
federal immigration laws New York City
is a sanctuary city as well as several
cities in California including Los
Angeles and San Francisco it's ludicrous
it's petulant democratic California
Governor Gavin Newsom slammed the move
as political retaliation against areas
refusing to bend to the president's
hardline stance on immigration to use
immigrants as pawns to put them in
difficult and trying circumstances as
political theater shows how low a human
being can go and this human happens to
be sadly and tragically the president
United States but as president Trump
looks ahead to 2020 immigration is an
issue he uses to galvanize his base
sanctuary cities that get Americans
killed they're immoral
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi whose home
city is San Francisco and it's just
another notion that is unworthy of the
presidency of the United States and
disrespectful the challenges that we
face as a country as a people to address
who we are a nation of immigrants the
president is denying reports he offered
pardons to DHS officials for breaking
immigration law
he also says he'll increase the number
of US troops at the southern border
Michelle all right Steve thank you